i want to start today sort of by talking
a little bit about 2022 and the midterms
we've been saying we don't yet really
know
how strong the challenges will be
against these various trumpian members
of congress marjorie taylor green lauren
bobert madison cawthorne and then you
know folks like matt gates and many
others there's no uh shortage of of of
folks who need to be seriously
challenged and hopefully removed there
is a very interesting new ad
from madison cothorns opponent
basically framing madison cawthorne as
the type of person that would end up
being radicalized into a domestic
terrorist almost kind of framing madison
cawthorne does the ad
as like a timothy mcveigh type
and you know we've talked about madison
cawthorne before
he's a guy who remember he had this
controversy where he vacationed at like
hitler's vacation home or like did
tourism at hitler's vacation home and
seemed sort of like relishing right
seemed to relish being in where there
was what he called supreme evil but
there was something like a little bit
fanboyish about it it was all really
weird
um he's sort of alluded to bringing guns
on the house floor he got caught trying
to bring a gun on his carry-on luggage
onto a plane says he didn't know it was
there um then brought a knife to a
school board meeting last week in north
carolina you know just a really a guy
who's really a problematic radical who
has made it clear he's not about policy
at all he's just about memes and pr and
communication and tweeting and this type
of thing
check out this ad we're going to look at
um so there's a great uh article about
this race on lgbtq nation
which says madison cawthorne has become
one of the loudest and most extreme
voices in the modern republican party
now his democratic opponent a lesbian
minister
is pointing out what has happened in
front of voter's eyes the congressman
like many young men has been radicalized
by extremists and fits the stereotype
now for a would-be domestic terrorist
jasmine beach ferrara tweeted with a
copy of the ad quote like too many young
people before him from around the world
to right right next door
madison cawthorne exhibits the signs of
a young man who has been radicalized by
extremists and is now dangerously
radicalizing others in the short spot
beech ferrara notes that hawthorne
started out claiming he was interested
in unity and bipartisanship before
switching to violent rhetoric and urging
insurrection let's take a look at the ad
because this is a very interesting
approach to one maybe one way to deal
with some of these trumpian extremists
that fundamentally are very
anti-american in terms of the values
they bring forward but they're framed as
being very patriotic let's take a look
like too many young people before him
from around the world to right next door
[Music]
madison hawthorne exhibits the signs of
a young man who has been radicalized by
extremists and is now dangerously
radicalizing others
in six months madison hawthorne went
from this we're someone who can really
help ease this partisan divide that's
going on our country right now to
stoking insurrection wow this crowd has
some fight in it and now eight months
later he calls these violent
insurrectionists political hostages and
can't let go of the big lie because you
know if our election systems continue to
be rigged and continue to be stolen it's
going to lead to one place in its
bloodshed republican congressman madison
cawthorne warning of quote bloodshed
again justifying potential violence
i'm jasmine beech ferrara as a mom an
ordained minister and a county
commissioner i'm running to defeat
madison hawthorne not by confronting
hate with more hate but with love of
neighbor
love of community and love of country
because violent extremism has no place
in western north carolina this isn't who
we are and we need to be crystal clear
about the difference between right and
wrong
madison cawthorn is a danger to our
democracy i'm asking for your help not
just to defeat him but to come together
to create the america our kids deserve
yeah
so you know i think unfortunately
um because this authoritarian slide
has happened over time
and this departure from norms and the
way we used to talk about political
issues it all it coarsened slowly as
we've talked about when donald trump
won in november of 2016.
we had a bad feeling about what was
going to happen but if i had told you
that day
what 2020 would look like under donald
trump all of the insanity and all of the
people
that would be elected in 2018 and 2020
uh in that trumpian vein it wouldn't
have seemed believable to most people
but it happened slowly over time and
then now all of a sudden what really are
radical extremists and if their religion
was a different one
we would be calling these people
probably terrorists there would be the
right would certainly be calling them
terrorists there's no doubt about it but
because they're
ostensibly christian
and because they're republicans and
because they subscribe or appeal to
this very myopic sense of what it means
to be for america
they've gotten a pass thanks to the slow
slide towards radicalization that has
taken place but what this ad does a
really good job of is
showing
put it all together you know uh tourism
in the house of the fuhrer
these outrageous videos that have like a
columbine shooter vibe of him punching
and punching and punching a tree as some
kind of training that he's doing and
shooting guns and talking about there
might be bloodshed if we don't fix our
election system of course placating the
same uh believers of the big lie that
actually did the writing on january 6
when you put it together
this is a very astute political ad
because it's not making the allegations
wildly or in an ad hominem sense or
without context it's just showing look
at this and if we took that video and
those statements by madison cawthorne
and you changed them and it was
equivalent but a muslim
uh or even just a democrat making
similar types of of claims which i i
mean i can't imagine whatever happened
uh they would be saying shouldn't the
fbi be investigating this guy and of
course we've said many times actually
yeah the fbi should be investigating
this guy so a really really interesting
ad by jasmine beech ferrara
it's great to see that there are people
challenging these wild outrageous people
how well they'll do in 2022 we just
don't know yet it's too early to say but
what we can say for sure is
if we are really going to like beat back
trumpism and maybe even prevent trump
from running in 2024
it's going to depend on
uh removing some of these people from
elected office
in november of 2022 jasmine beach
ferrara one possibility in madison
cawthorne's district will have more time
to cover her race and many of these
other ones as we go forward
this is a very
strange headline
donald trump
has filed a lawsuit
against his own niece as well as the new
york times now let me translate i'm
going to tell you the story but let me
translate it for you reporters
investigated things that were newsworthy
and donald trump really doesn't like it
and he's suing
okay here's the article from cnbc
former president donald trump filed a
100 million dollar lawsuit tuesday
against his niece mary trump and the new
york times claiming they conspired to
obtain his tax returns for the paper's
pulitzer prize-winning store pulitzer
winning story on his undisclosed
finances the lawsuit asserts that mary
trump and three new york times reporters
suzanne craig david barstow and russell
bettner were engaged in what the suit
calls an insidious plot and an extensive
crusade to obtain trump's taxes now
notice none of these
so far none of that signals a crime
right what they mean is there was a
newsworthy story around trump's taxes
and trump hiding his taxes
and
there was
an awareness of that among investigative
reporters who tried to obtain them now
then it gets to allegations that at
least in theory could could be criminal
uh the defendants engaged in an
insidious plot to obtain confidential
and highly sensitive records which they
exploited for their own benefit and
utilized as a means of falsely
legitimizing their publicized works it's
still
very weak like what are the damages and
what is the wrongdoing here craig
barstow and wetner received the pulitzer
prize in 2019 for explanatory reporting
for their series of stories which
provided the public with an
unprecedented look at the former
president's finances mary trump has said
she released trump's tax returns to the
new york times in her best-selling 2020
book about her uncle too much and never
enough how my family created the world's
most dangerous man and in media
interviews which the lawsuit notes in
the book the daughter of trump's brother
fred jr paints an authoritative portrait
of donald j trump and the toxic family
that made him
reacting to this in a statement mary
trump called her uncle desperate quote i
think he's a loser and he is going to
throw anything against the wall he can
it's desperation the walls are closing
in and he is throwing anything against
the wall that he thinks will stick as is
always the case with donald he'll try
and change the subject the new york
times said in a statement it plans to
challenge the lawsuit statement from a
spokesperson for the paper danielle
rhodes says quote the times coverage of
donald trump's taxes helped inform
citizens through meticulous reporting on
a subject of overriding public interest
this lawsuit is an attempt to silence
independent news organizations and we
plan to vigorously defend against it
lawsuit filed in new york state court
um it alleges a relentlet that the
reporter relentlessly sought out his
niece and convinced her to smuggle the
records out of her attorney's office and
turn them over to the time so what is
what is this really about this is about
trump's furious reporters investigated
and reported on something that was
newsworthy and trump wants to punish
them now of course at any time donald
trump could publish his taxes
and prove the story wrong if the
conclusions of these stories about his
taxes are out of context or they're not
complete right if trump believes what
was released of my taxes is incomplete
and it paints an incorrect picture
release the full taxes and then we'll
actually get the full picture he could
do that at any time to prove the story
wrong but this is all distract distract
distract and i i don't think it's also
crazy to consider
whether
the real news of the last five days
is number one
that uh when trump and his team were
pushing the big lie about the 2020
election
they knew that it was a lie that we've
learned more so over the last week
the document with the six-point plan
outlining how donald trump wanted to use
mike pence to steal the election
that came to light over the last five
days and so to some degree this entire
lawsuit may just be an attempt to
distract from that but i believe it will
go absolutely nowhere nowhere i would be
i'm not a betting man but i would be
willing to bet that this goes absolutely
nowhere and maybe someday we will get
trump's taxes although at this point do
we do we even still care i know there
are some in my audience who do others
who say who even cares at this point but
remember he might be back in 2024
um and so all of us being equal i do
think it would be a great thing to
finally get a hold of those taxes let me
know your thoughts if you disagree you
can find me on twitter at deepakman we
have a fantastic program for you today
and it continues right after this short
break
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
remember that our program is mostly
funded by viewers and listeners who get
memberships at joinpackman.com we do an
extra show every day weekdays guys come
on not seven days a week that'd be crazy
weekdays we do an extra show for our
members called the bonus show it is
award-winning although we create and
give the awards so it may not be worth
that much
uh we also offer commercial free audio
and video streams of the show every day
to our members
you can sign up at joinpackman.com
let's talk to people in the audience the
audience matters and we take calls via
the david pakman show discord which you
can find
at davidpakman.com
discord
we're going to start today
with david from saint petersburg now is
that st petersburg florida or st
petersburg russia
hi david yes at st petersburg florida
love it
uh thank you for allowing me to call
i've been listening to show for about
two years and i really enjoy hearing
your perspective on a lot of issues
that's great david and please silence
those discord notifications they're
already going off
uh
yes sir yeah um
yes um so my my question is
i'm
i'm pretty moderate i would say
however i'm
i'm having a little bit of an issue with
what i'm seeing sort of out of the left
right now
and what i mean by that is i almost see
free markets being almost a swear word
when i'm having lots of discussions with
my friends
and they're talking about how it's a
failed system and we have to move past
it and they often use nordic countries
as an example however i i know nordic
countries to be very free markets that
mainly
use free markets to generate revenue in
order to pay for their social programs
which
which is great and it works wonderful
for them
however i always hear people talking
about a need to move past this system
but i haven't seen any system that works
for everybody and creates a society that
they want to create that is equitable
and have people be happy and taken care
of without a robust free market in order
to have taxes that are then taken out of
them to provide services for people
well this is just fundamentally a
question of what is one's political and
economic philosophy you
one thing is we've got to first be
accurate when they say we got to move
past the free market and be like norway
norway denmark sweden these countries
have markets
for the vast majority of goods and
services but what they've done is
they've said there should be some areas
where
there is either extremely
disproportionate power for things that
are necessary in the market like you
know health care education etc where
we're going to take things out of the
free market so the first thing is to say
we've got to get away from free markets
and be like norway it doesn't make any
sense some of a lot of those countries
have very good business environments
with a lot of freedom so we have to
start with the facts first of all
secondly
i
am thinking
some of the people that you're talking
about
might be actual socialists or even
communists is is that right because for
the most part if you're just
a social democrat like i am you're not
saying eliminate free markets
you're just saying there are some areas
that should be removed from the market
but it's fine for markets to direct
resources on mobile phones you know dvd
players what whatever the case may be
it's just that there's certain areas
where we need more government
involvement
yes i i agree with what you're saying
the main issues i have is i don't they
don't categorize themselves as
socialists or
communists or they just say they're
liberal democrats and
they look at policies i i believe that
they don't look at the sort of the
funding necessary for some of these
policies as well you know for example
when we look at the nordic countries
they have these ideas that the rich and
the wealthy can fund everything and
it's just impossible with everything
they say that is available
you know such as the health care and
well to a great degree the
disproportionate amount of funding for
those things actually can easily come
from the very very rich but i i it's
sounding like the people you're talking
to are sort of all over the place and
they may not really know what they're
talking about because a lot of these
arguments kind of conflict and you know
i i wouldn't judge these movements by
the people you're specifically talking
to maybe would be my advice really try
not to i really try not to it just seems
that maybe it's just spending too much
time online and just
talking to
you know people that are more of the
millennial age i mean you're a very very
educated person and most people that are
educated such as yourself and in the
political
spectrum you know clearly have moved
past that idea however i just see a very
large portion of the voting bloc
not necessarily being so well informed
as you are cause
you know obviously i bring these points
up to you and you're just
rightfully saying oh well that's silly
you know that's not actually how it
works and that's not how it is yeah i
mean listen it sounds like you're saying
a lot of people are engaging in politics
and not having any idea what's going on
and i would agree there's a lot of that
on the left and right but that's more of
a systemic education issue i would say
yes yes i i agree it's just
i see what you're saying it's just
it seems that i'm just seeing him more
and more from you know 15 years ago and
i just get worried when elections happen
that
i'm not saying this is really gonna
happen i know
but you know maybe 20 years from now
just
people voting for policies that could
end up being more
aimed towards venezuela rather than a
nordic country that has a very happy
successful population yeah we're very
very far from that there there's nobody
even proposing venezuela type policy
right now in any serious way so we'll
watch that we'll watch that all right
david from st petersburg thank you so
much for the call i appreciate the uh
um commentary from you
let's go next to
sam from minnesota sam from minnesota
you're on the air
oh hi that's my volume your volume is
beautiful
okay um do you really think better
o'rourke is a good gubernatorial
candidate for democrats in texas you
know he had a statewide race in 2018 and
lost to ted cruz of all people and that
was before he told texans hell yeah i'm
coming for your guns so i don't really
have another candidate in mind but with
so many people in texas do you really
think beto is the best texas democrats
have to offer i don't know uh we talked
about this a little bit earlier in the
week when when on the bonus show the
topic of beto running i think what beto
has going for him are a couple different
things number one name recognition to
some degree now name recognition can be
bad as you point out if he's known to
texas republicans as the guy who wants
to take your guns so name recognition
can be a double-edged sword um i think
beto also has going for him that
he
can definitely rebut greg abbott's
failed policy
very well and directly and eloquently
and articulately
but i don't know if he's the best person
to to run against abbott but i'm with
you in that i can't really think of
anybody else
so i'm excited about the idea that
because abbott's approval is in the
toilet maybe someone with name
recognition like beto could actually
sweep in and do a good job obviously as
i mentioned earlier in the week they're
going to run against him on hey these
democrats want to take your guns forget
about the covet disaster forget about
the electricity disaster betto is going
to take your guns i think that could be
a problem but i don't have any better
ideas right now
uh that's fair the other day you were
talking about how you felt the
interviews with families of anti-vax
people who died of covid felt really
exploitative sometimes they do sometimes
they do yeah yeah well i've thought a
term i've thought of a term for that
kind of thing and i want to know what
you think of it of exploitation
vaxploitation yeah i mean the thing
about it is that could mean
exploiting people who did get it or who
didn't i mean it's not super precise but
it's not a bad idea i kind of like it
yeah
yeah it's just a play on the old black
exploitation films
what about anti-vaxxploy
uh
maybe okay it's getting a little long i
think it's a little too long yeah it
works i think you're right i think
you're right yeah no i mean do you so do
you agree that sometimes those
interviews feel a little exploitative
and like disaster porny
yeah i mean it's just the nature of you
know these new shows that are looking
for content yeah fair fair all right i
appreciate the call
oh sure sure i was about to ask you if
you think we'll be back to normal by
mid-22 but uh i think we'll be back to
normal by by mid 32
no i have no idea i don't know i hope so
but who knows i think kova is going to
be around a couple years at least
sure thanks
all right thank you for the call i
appreciate that
let's um let's speak to some other
people because there there's really a
lot of people here who want to get on
let's go next to alicia from cancun
mexico you're on the air
hello
alicia alicia from cancun you're on if
you unmute will be able to hear you
and last opportunity for alicia slash
alicia from cancun you must unmute to
speak to me
otherwise the tubes won't work
all right that's too bad
let's stay in cancun and go to eric from
cancun instead eric are you on the air
hmm
eric from cancun you're on
wow
something must be going on with the
internet there
in uh in cancun
let's go next to i hope i'm pronouncing
this correctly is it ishan from amherst
yeah that's correct hey david how's it
going it's going well thank you
thanks for picking up my phone call um
so my question to you is on sunday the
parliamentarian elizabeth mcdonough
ruled that the democrats can't include
all the immigration provisions in the
reconciliation bill
now
the
um senate majority leader chuck schumer
and dick durbin they're all being like
oh we have plan b we're gonna go back to
her with another proposal
my question to you is why are they
begging an unelected official why can't
they simply overrule her or ignore her
um i know that in 2001 republicans did
the same thing they probably fired the
parliamentarian when millions of lives
are at stake um
do you have any do you know like why are
they just like not playing hardball and
like just like ignoring her altogether
ishaan i agree with you completely this
notion that now is sort of like just
assumed to be true
that the parliamentarian just gets to
decide uh i i challenge that and i've
read a couple of good pieces arguing
that you don't re it's sort of like by
tradition
that the parliamentarian is given
um
uh the ability to weigh in on these
things and that times have sort of
changed and that quite frankly i mean
this term has a negative connotation but
they could just steamroll the
parliamentarian if they wanted and then
deal with it later let republicans say
i'm against it because it's out of order
right or whatever but i completely agree
with you and i think it's ridiculous the
way they're handling the parliamentarian
but do you think there's any chance with
joe manchin christian cinema and
in the senate
that um they're gonna even like think
about um
bringing the bill with the provisions on
the floor and let kamala harris just
ignore her ruling
um
i i don't i think it depends on the bill
to be perfectly honest i'm not sure i
think it depends i think there maybe yes
i'd have to think a little more about
that
hey thank you so much david thank you so
much for taking my phone call um i don't
know if you remember but like i called
last year too i would talk but yeah
probably not but
remind me sean are you in amherst
massachusetts or amherst new york
amherst massachusetts i go to umass oh
you do oh my god i just heard 350
positive cases last week at umass
yeah there was like a party in an
off-campus gathering townhouses yeah um
honestly speaking
if if i'm gonna level with you i've
stopped caring because i feel like
there's nothing i can do people are
gonna party left and right yeah uh
i i can't help it so like there's no
point like thinking about it just like
it just it's not conducive to my own
well-being i cannot focus on other stuff
i totally sympathize with that
which which townhouses was the party at
um the town houses which is like in
sunderland oh those town oh wow okay
okay yeah yeah that was like a mass
congregation and i feel like there's
nothing i can do that that's gonna
change to drive the numbers one way or
the other yeah so what's the point of
stressing out about it i am fully
vaccinated i take care of myself i just
like i'm just moving on i just like live
my own life whatever happens happens i i
can't do anything at this point i
understand ishaan it sounds like you're
doing all the right things anyway so
yeah thank you so much all right
pleasure there's ishan from umass
my undergraduate alma mater wow what a
call
what a call
why don't we go next to um let's go to
win from indiana win you're on the air
is win short for something
hi david can you hear me
yes i can
okay uh wynn is not short from from uh
for anything i'm actually originally
from thailand but i moved to indiana a
couple of months ago how was that
uh it's different i'm just here for
college but yes it's different
all right yeah
i have a question in regards to demand
versus
uh supply economics sure so i was i'm
talking to my uncle who's from las vegas
and he sort of agreed with the idea of
demand economics and that you know
demand drives
businesses and whatnot
but he used the example of las vegas
saying that
before vegas was in the middle of the
desert but because of you know like
low regulation lower taxes it uh
encourages businesses to
um
uh open up casinos
and therefore you know there was more
business activity
so i was just curious like what are your
what are your thoughts on that uh
argument i see so let me see if i i want
to make sure i understand the argument
it sounds like you're saying your uncle
generally believes that demand is what
drives businesses to open there's demand
for a product or service so that's an
opportunity for a business to enter but
with vegas his argument is
in vegas what created all of these
casinos and hotels and all this stuff is
that there was low regulation so it was
attractive rather than demand driven am
i hearing that correctly
yes okay i think the counterpoint would
be
and i think it's a it's a it's a natural
one in a sense
there was already pent-up demand for
what vegas initially offered it was
demand from all over the united states
there was already even if people did not
necessarily know what we're looking for
is a gaming paradise in the desert or
whatever you had a population that was
big enough with diverse enough interests
that there was
a pent-up demand
and so that's why
business people when they
said hey
let's what about a casino vegas is a
good place the low regulation may have
been why they chose vegas
but the demand generally for a gaming
industry was already there
i see
okay
so so do you think uh it depends on
particular services or products that
uh supply or demand is going to be the
determining factor do you think you know
there are some cases that supply may
drive
um businesses
yeah so so listen here's the thing this
is a this is a quite an involved topic
there are products and services that
benefit for example from network effects
where actually more supply
increases the perceived value of the
product or service and supply can
actually drive demand there are luxury
goods where you actually might sometimes
see supply and demand interact in
different ways than a typical supply and
demand group there's really no one
answer to this and one can generally
speaking
understand that demand drives hiring
while still realizing that there are
other types of situations that we have
to sort of account for separately
right i see
wow that was a that was great out yeah
the idea of pent up demand yeah i didn't
think of that awesome thank you so much
my plea yeah and last thing
yeah the low regulation alone if there
was no pent-up demand for hotels and
casinos
you can go whether there's low or high
regulation and build a hotel in casino
if nobody wants to be in a casino it's
not going to matter that the regulation
was low you understand what i'm saying
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah all right thank you i appreciate
the call
thank you all right win from thailand
now
in indiana let's take a quick break
don't hang up if you're holding because
we're going to get right back to a few
more calls right after this short break
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show all right let's speak
to a few more people via the david
pakman show discord which you can find
at davidpakman.com
slash discord it is a great discord i
highly highly recommend it
let's go next to will from la now is
that los angeles or louisiana
it's uh los angeles all right welcome
how you doing um so i i
sorry if this has already been brought
up before but curious about your
thoughts on this gabby petito thing
obviously it's a huge story but then on
one side you hear a lot of people um
kind of irritated that a lot of black
and indigenous and hispanic people
aren't getting the same
uh
you know sort of visibility for their
case i'm just curious what your thoughts
on that are i mean i i personally think
it's
really
tough to
demean this poor girl's existence to
demean her own individual case um
by you know complaining about
maybe other cases that don't get the
same sort of coverage and i'm just
curious what your thoughts on that are
yeah so there's really three stories
here and we talked about this on a bonus
show earlier this week so first there's
just the facts of the gabby petito story
um as of this moment her her fiance
brian laundry is missing there's
speculation as to you know his
involvement in her disappearance and
subsequent death etc etc so there's the
facts of that story and the way that
it's been reported these stories they do
really well particularly for local news
stations like i think there's a station
in tampa that has just
done really well covering every aspect
of this and so it's sort of like a car
chase fox news starts covering the car
chase etc so there's that and the
salacious nature of the initial story
then you started to see commentaries
from like joy read on msnbc and some
other places saying hey you know what
this is missing white girl syndrome if
this was a black woman if this was an
indigenous woman or whatever
you would not be seeing this amount of
coverage newsweek even had an article
where they said hey you know what gabby
petito met went missing in wyoming over
the last decade 466 indigenous women
have gone missing in wyoming none of
them got this amount of coverage i think
to some degree that's true
i also think it's a combination of
factors it's pretty 22 year old white
girl
some social media notoriety
a 90 minute or hour long police stop
body cam video
that adds to the mystique and it adds to
the story
the fiance goes miss you know i think
that there are more aspects to it but i
think to some degree there is a
difference in coverage based on the
identity of the of the victim and then
the third story is
many of the media outlets criticizing
the coverage saying when it's a black
woman or an indigenous woman we don't
get the coverage they also never covered
the missing black or indigenous women
which is like the third layer which is
they are making headlines talking about
the disparity but they contributed to
that very same disparity you know what
i'm saying well
i
totally agree with that point absolutely
so in terms of not demeaning this what
happened to gabby petito i'm with you
like her case is no less tragic
because of these other meta stories like
it's sort of like running through a
cancer fundraiser and saying what about
aids right like i i get that
it's still important to understand why
certain stories get more coverage than
others though
absolutely yeah it really is important
to understand and and i feel for for
anybody that goes missing it doesn't
matter they're they're you know gender
or race or anything i mean it's it's
terrible and i just
i i hope that there's more light that
that is shined on those people you know
on on anybody that goes missing and i
also you know hope uh for some sort of
healing for you know gabby's gabby's
family and people who loved her and and
uh yeah it's just it's terrible all
around anybody who goes missing but
thank you so much for your time david i
really appreciate you big fan of the
show thanks will will from la very much
appreciate the call and uh a good topic
i mean there's a lot of different
stories there that's uh that's the
reality
let's go next to itai
from one of my favorite cities in the
world
copenhagen denmark itai you are on the
air
hi david it's good to speak to you
pleasure
all right so i have a hypothesis about
why american politics is the way it is
okay and basically it's this
the american electoral system
um allows us to have um basically the
worst
allows both parties to be um
basically
unaccountable and still win because
if you look at it um technically
speaking
the rules are that
you you only have to perform uh better
than everyone else
sort of
individually we call it um a single
winner system
and um
that actually guarantees that you have a
two-party system like you have in
america
um
where you know you have um
uh what is it a party like the
republican party that's just a cult now
and i think that um if uh that that is
really the main problem with american uh
politics so let me see if i understand
so basically what you're saying is
no matter how bad republicans are or get
in terms of being radical in terms of
being a cult in terms of being unhinged
in any particular election where they
can claim to be slightly less bad than
democrats they have a shot at winning
and that's a real problem
yes yeah i agree with you i'm
yeah in in denmark we use something
called uh proportional representation
where the amount of vote you get is
proportional to how much people
um support your opinion
and i i'm thinking just
it's it's kind of um
miserable that abysmal that we live in
uh or you people in america have to live
in a system where um they're not able to
um have a different option because um
the way the american system works is you
only have to get a plurality you don't
have to get more than
um like if you get a really huge number
of votes or if you have a lot of support
your idea won't um get into uh
government like um if you look at the
the percentage of people in congress
support or oppose something like
medicare for all and then you compare a
policy in denmark
and uh you
you compare the how the government the
people in government the parliament
support oppose a policy compared to the
population as a whole it's there's a
very strong correlation but there isn't
in america because
the um system just allows the worst kind
of people to um win elections yeah this
is just a feature of the first past the
post plurality system that we have now
you know in some cases you actually do
have to get a majority so if no one gets
50 there's a runoff but okay we can put
that aside for now you can have a
district
where 45 of the population wants
medicare for all
and 45 of the voters vote for the
candidate that wants medicare for all
that candidate loses
and the representation of that district
which is 45 percent for medicare for all
is only one elected official who does
not support medicare for all that's just
a fundamental problem with the system
that we have it's a there's no way
around it it's just the way it is
but if we use the danish system of
course
i think they wouldn't the republicans
would never win another election or
maybe they would still have supporters
but they would never be in office again
well hold on a second because with a
system like that
you could also have republicans from
some of the minority republican
districts that are only represented by a
democrat right now i mean there's two
sides to that
well i guess but at least we wouldn't
one product of the proportional system
is that you actually have um like a
multi-party system so we'd at least know
where people stand because i know that
there are people who vote um republican
who are act actually have populist
opinions and would probably vote for a
different party if they had a better
very true system to go to but there
would be democrats uh also who might
vote you know green party or something
else as well but i think it's a very
very interesting proposal
listen we keep reading about how great
things are in denmark 75 plus percent
vaccination are is anybody wearing masks
anywhere at this point
not at all no masks and things are okay
things are great
wow wow i really miss it i it's really
copenhagen is such a great city the
biking the bike lanes the food is
fantastic
uh it's just so great you know
yeah i love it
well i hope to get back there soon i
appreciate the call
thank you david have a nice day there is
itai from copenhagen denmark what a
special city
what a special city my friends
let's go next let's go elsewhere okay
let's go to richard from california
richard you're on the air
richard please go right into your
question my friend
hello can you hear me yes i can hi david
i've been a
long time listener first time caller um
i really like i especially really like
your coverage during the capital right
it really turned my dad from a
conservative to moderate wow that's good
all right so i've been living in los
angeles for a long long time okay and
lately i just been noticing that there's
been like a lack of empathy for
the homeless population
and
my main concern is that because
there are some groups who are
or who are help who are trying to help
the homeless but the problem is that
there's like a large like pushback like
even our own sheriff even like when
there was a plan to do like affordable
housing or free housing for them
our sheriff said that oh no like it's
gonna like it's gonna entice people from
other states to come to our states but
he never offered like the solution to it
right
yeah so my like my main concern like
eventually like my question is that
do you think eventually like
our um representatives or people will
start like calling like on for
the homeless to be sent to like death
valley or
to be like i don't want to i mean listen
there's already people calling for that
sort of thing i mean it almost starts to
get concentration campy you know here's
the thing
we we've had enough pilot programs at
this point to know how to deal with a
problem of homelessness which is first
you've got to provide the resources and
allow people to learn and make sure you
help people learn that they exist and
it's cheaper
to house feed and provide health care to
homeless people
than to criminalize homelessness or to
try to push homeless people around to
different places it just makes more
economic sense
once you do that i'm open to the idea
that hey these resources are now
available if they are
now we can start an information campaign
about at a certain point the encampments
are not going to be allowed anymore why
well because we have the resources and
having the resources is key but just
shipping people off to death valley i
mean it's inhumane it's crazy that that
you know i hope that that doesn't happen
all right all right
yeah it's just been like i've been like
ever since i was young i just remember
like the homeless crisis
it was like small but now it's getting
worse and worse
yeah
yeah with the moratorium's ending it's
going to get real worse you remember a
lot of my um classmates in elementary
they lost their houses during the
the financial crisis in no way yeah it
was terrible
and um wow
yeah and a quick question
like do you think like do you think um
uh because i've been a long time
listener i was wondering like have you
kept in touch with lewis or do you think
he he can make a guest appearance on it
on a future show oh yeah i see louis
every couple weeks and he's welcome
anytime maybe he'll join me on a live
stream soon or something like that
oh all right well thank you for taking
my call my pleasure but what part of la
are you in generally
uh like in south central like like
southeast california got it okay all
right very good i appreciate the call
all right thank you david all right
thanks everybody who called in today i
will not be taking more calls right now
but we will take calls again
follow the david pakman show on social
media interact with me and other david
pakman show viewers you'll be able to
see when we're taking calls live on the
show we post hilarious video clips
you'll see exclusive show content not on
the show and you'll be the first to see
big announcements like upcoming guests
and more follow me on twitter at dpakman
and davidpakmanshow we're on instagram
david.pakman join the reddit community
at davidpakman.com reddit and you can
also find the david pakman show on
facebook
discord and tick tock it's almost too
easy all right let's get into your
emails the email bag so to speak it's
really more of a folder but you know i
think the imagery of the mailbag is
still
maybe relevant in modern society in 2021
info davidpakman.com is the place to
email let's see what's on some people's
minds first many responses
to my response to mickey minaj's tweet
about her
cousin's friend's testicle swelling you
guys remember this story phil wrote to
me and said technical response to
swollen apple bags
hey david just watched your episode and
thought you might want to read through
this yes of course it can occur with
stis but it can also occur via covid
itself apparently or mumps i'm
vaccinated and had a breakthrough case
along with my girlfriend a couple weeks
ago and was panicking when i noticed a
bit of inflammation on myself after
extensive googling because i currently
don't have health insurance through my
employer i live in texas big surprise
right
i came across a few articles like this
just wanted to send it your way since it
seems more likely to me that nicki
minaj's cousin's brother's dog sitter
twice removed probably just got exposed
to covet after getting the vaccine
then getting it from the vaccine or an
sti even although that's obviously
statistically more likely than getting
it from the vaccine yeah it's the the
ministry of health from trinidad and
tobago said we found no reporting at all
about this case of the swollen testicles
from the vaccine and i think if it is
even at all real which we don't know but
if it's a real story if nicki minaj's
cousin's friend's testicles really did
swell
it would almost certainly be from
something else could be coveted itself
could be
orchidus from gonorrhea chlamydia you
know something else
um also an email about tucker carlson's
interest in the swollen testicles of
nicki minaj's cousin's friend
jfk wrote in
and said tucker carlson's rant over
someone else's balls has a different
problem
how many men have experienced direction
issues under stress every man has at
some point the guy's fiance calls off
the wedding because he's dysfunctional
better that he found out now she didn't
really love him
let's take this to the bizarre far-right
bible-thumping side why is she having
sex before marriage
there is far more evidence that sars
cov2
can and does cause capillary dysfunction
in male testicles yeah that's another
story that was brought to light
accurately
which is
covet itself seems to carry a risk of
sexual dysfunction but i keep going back
that it is weird
that
because of a vaccine a supposed vaccine
reaction
nicki minaj's cousin's friend's fiancee
called off the wedding it's like well if
it's just a medical issue reacting to
the vaccine wouldn't wouldn't you just
get married anyway or it's all very very
strange
next email is from brendan
brendan writes in about the nova vaxx
vaccine
says hey david i believe we'll see
vaccination rates go up in this country
about 20
if the novovax vaccine ends up becoming
available in the u.s
many covid vaccine hesitant people who
are currently unvaccinated are holding
out for the novavax as its subunit
protein technology makes it closer to
traditional influenza vaccines it also
has greater than 90 efficacy from trials
and has been touted as likely the best
vaccine yet even by publications like
the atlantic have you read up on it
i have but not recently enough to know
whether these claims are still accurate
um brendan says anyway i think the vax
issue this is a vax issue worth
discussing i am open to and interested
in any efficacious and safe vaccine
being put forward
with the goal of it working for someone
who's not yet been vaccinated i hesitate
to put too much stock
in any people still not vaccinated
claiming i'll get vaccinated as soon as
x
because for the most part there's been a
lot of bs look at all the people who
said i'd get vaccinated as soon as the
vaccine is fda approved
the numbers have barely trickled up
since the pfizer vaccine was fda
approved weeks ago many of them have
moved on to something else including
saying
the approval is untrustworthy because it
was political or whatever the case may
be so i am really skeptical about any
one thing having that much of an impact
except
the airfare uh the air aviation thing i
do think that while it won't be the 41
of anti-vax people
who claimed they would get vaccinated if
you need one to fly i don't think 41
will actually go and do it i do have
every belief
that if a vaccine was required to fly a
lot of anti-vax people would go and get
vaccinated so novavax
uh
airline requirement you know do do
employee requirement
let's try everything to try to get those
numbers up
uh next
email
is from randall randall wrote in about
the january 5th january 6th pipe bomb
surveillance video these are the pipe
bombs
placed in dc on january 5th
found on january 6th in and around the
time that the trump riots were going on
randall says david i believe that you
and your friends are correct about the
suspect being a woman
as you watch the suspect as they sit
down on the bench they place their knees
together how many men do that definitely
a woman i actually didn't notice that
and i don't know much about that i've
never really paid attention to placing
knees together
when i sit down
yeah i guess i don't i don't put my
knees together but that's just me
i don't know if this is uh some kind of
gender stereotype if there's any basis
in science i really have no idea
uh i've also not heard anything
additional about the identity of the
pipe bomb suspect and it is so difficult
for me to believe that nobody knows a
thing about it it's just really really
difficult to imagine that that's the
case
um
hopefully we will know something soon
and yeah i got a lot of emails
after the segment last week from people
saying i agree with you david i do think
that the suspect is a woman that may
have been because i mentioned it i don't
i really don't know i have no idea but
if you know anything please please
please
contact the fbi very very important
stuff
next email is from paul
paul writes to me
the only legitimate anti-vaxx argument
so i thought this should be good let's
see what paul says
dear david
while most of the arguments i've heard
from the anti-vaxxers are based on
conspiracy theories or simply
scientifically inaccurate
there is one legitimate reason for
vaccine hesitancy that i can't argue
against we don't know
the long-term effects of these vaccines
we don't know that five to ten years
from now vaccinated individuals won't be
dropping debt of heart attacks what do
you say to people who have these fears
and what makes you so confident you
won't develop long-term side effects
cheers paul this is not a new argument
okay
there is this is an indefeasible
argument because you can always argue
however long a vaccine's been out
we don't yet know
that some kind of side effect doesn't
start right after that the polio vaccine
it's been out 70 years
how do we know
that on year 71 the polio vaccine
doesn't cause some kind of problem it's
and the problem with this argument is
it's indefeasible you can't defeat this
argument because you could always say
well the vaccine's been out 11 years the
problems might start after 12 years so
my feeling on this is based on speaking
to doctors and virologists and
epidemiologists about how the vaccine
works and how the substance of the
vaccine clears from your body relatively
quickly
i have no reason to believe
that there is some magical period of
time after which there will be some new
problem in addition to that with the
with a very narrow exception about gbs
guillain-barre syndrome which we've
talked about and which is now better
understood
there aren't examples of what this
person is saying either so it's not
about why am i personally so confident i
won't have a long-term side effect in
five years and 10 years whatever from
the vaccine
the decades-long research on mrna
technology
and now
the century of vaccination
uh century plus actually if you include
you know smallpox
tells us that that does not seem to be
how vaccine works and so that's why i've
made the decision to go and get
vaccinated but this is the type of
argument that you can never defeat
because they could always say listen if
okay the vaccine causes no side effects
for a hundred years if life spans
increase we don't know what that vaccine
could do you can always make that
argument it really gets us nowhere it's
not supported by evidence
okay and then kurt wrote to me
kurt wrote to me about rules during the
pandemic kurt says
an old newspaper article from 1918
showing a list of do's and don'ts for
preventing the spanish flu
looks painfully familiar my favorite is
this one quote
do not disregard the advice of a
specialist
just because you
do not understand
yeah i mean it's it's sort of depressing
in a sense that
we have all these new medical
technologies uh mrna vaccine we're
developing we have all these new
treatments and we have you know ecmo
machines and ventilators and all these
different things but to just stop the
spread
it's hygiene
it's physical distance
and it's masking that's basically what
he did what it is this really hasn't
changed
and yet still we have so many people who
either don't understand it or refuse to
do it or think they know better than the
experts or believe the experts are part
of some conspiracy it there's a lot of
stuff and we interviewed an author who
who's uh an historian a historian and
historian
of uh the 1918 flu
and he told us about a lot of the same
dynamics science skeptical people people
refusing to participate in the
guidelines etc
a hundred years ago i mean 103 years ago
at this point in time
some things never change seemingly or at
least they take a really long time to
change
send me your emails maybe they will be
picked and featured on next week's email
bag
info
davidpakman.com we've got a great bonus
show coming up for you today you can
sign up at
joinpacman.com please sign up it really
is a great revenue source for us it
makes us
independent of big media and advertisers
because it's just you guys you guys
control the show you fund the show
you can sign up at joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21
we'll see you on the bonus show if
you're not so inclined then we will talk
to you on monday